the opening scene features a man named
Milo Stanfield who is suffering from
autism spectrum disorder or ASD he is
seen standing on a street of New Jersey
keeping an eye on a woman in a nearby
flower shop in the midst of this he also
seems to be doing some complex
calculations related to the timing of
events happening in his surroundings
Milo notes the approach of a passenger
bus a pothole a street artist and a
bicycle Rider speeding following these
observations he crosses the street and
strategically places es a pen on the top
of a mailbox adjacent to the pothole
soon after his planned chain reaction
takes place a taxi runs over the pothole
splashing the water on the pen causing
it to fall to the ground this captures
the attention of the street artist who
then walks forward to pick up the pen at
the same moment the speeding cyclist
collides with the artist which results
in him striking the mailbox and falling
on the Fruit Stand nearby chaos ensues
in the street diverting the attention of
everyone including the bus driver as a
result he does not notice the traffic
light turning red and hits the same
woman crossing the road killing her on
the spot and people say math isn't
dangerous Milo then walks away from the
scene after confirming that his plan
went smoothly the scene then cuts to an
FBI special agent Olivia Dunham she
works for The Fringe division of
Homeland Security specializing in
paranormal phenomena Olivia seems to be
returning back to work after a long Gap
due to her head injury as soon as she
enters the fr headquarters she is
greeted by one of her fellow officers
Charlie who is the supervisor of the
team in the meantime the chief of the
agency walternate bishop is talking to
one of the lab assistants Philip bro
regarding Olivia's return Philip says
that she is a doppelganger named faux
Olivia and expresses concern if they can
integrate an impostor in their team here
it is revealed that Olivia who is inside
the office is not the real one she is in
fact an impostor who has been brought to
fulfill the place of the original one
walternate then Reveals His motivation
behind keeping fivia in this universe
and implanting the real Olivia's
memories into her he claims that fivia
is the only one who can travel between
universes without any harm walternate
wants to figure out how she can do so
for this he says that they must make her
believe that she belongs here Philip
asks what if her new identity does not
hold to which the chief replies that she
will no longer be necessary after that
afterwards Charlie br briefs the team on
the seemingly random bus accident which
he claims to have happened two times in
this week the victim has died in each
case he then asks his crew to be careful
before going for the site investigation
a short while later the FBI team arrives
at the accident site and splits up to
search for any leads or Clues the
investigation is led by another FBI
agent named Lincoln Lee whose face
appears to be ruined by burn marks
Charlie inspects the body and uses her
fingerprint to retrieve her further
details she event finds out that the
deceased woman's name is Julian Foster
meanwhile Olivia questions the bus
driver who is shaken by the incident as
he has never even hit any birds or
animals until now simultaneously Agent
Lee tests for any signs of environmental
factors but finds nothing however he
does find the same ballpoint pen at the
scene after inquiring with the
eyewitnesses Olivia approaches Agent Lee
and tells him that the local artist had
bent down to pick up the pen during
which he collided with the bicycle Rider
and fell into the Fruit Stand upon
hearing this Agent Lee speculates that
the pen is the main element that created
a sequence of reactions ultimately
leading to the victim's death the next
day at French headquarters Agent Lee and
Charlie are trying to find out a
connection between the bus accidents
that happened in the two days Agent Lee
spots the same ballpoint pen in the
photo of the first accident which makes
him even more convinced that someone has
orchestrated the chain of events
following this they go to talk to a
mathematician of the fr agency astred
and tell her about the events however
she claims that no human can carry out
such a chain of events and mold it in
his or her favor twice amidst their
argument another similar bus accident
takes place leaving astd in shock two
plus two equals you get hit by a bus the
FBI agents immediately rush to the site
and find that the victims are still
alive this time upon questioning the
bystanders they learned that a dog
suddenly crossed the road causing the
bus to lose control just then Olivia
notices a similar ballpoint pen rolling
down in the ground which makes her
realize that the chain of events is not
over yet she looks around and spots a
suspicious Milo looking down from an
overhead Bridge moments later a man
wearing earbuds walks forward to cross
the street only to be hit by an oncoming
ambulance I guess the paramedic needed
to hit his quota with her suspicions
confirmed Olivia alerts her team and
races towards Milo seeing this the
ladder instantly calculates Ates another
series of events and throws a bicycle
off the bridge this prompts a bus to
change its path and drive right under
the overhead Bridge Olivia holds him at
gunpoint threatening him to surrender
but Milo jumps off the bridge lands on
the bus's roof and gets away Milo is the
bus Whisperer after this event Milo
returns home to find his sister mateline
worried for him she tells him that she
has been getting numerous calls from the
hospital but he ignores her she then
tries to convince him to surrender
claiming that he is gone way too far
however Milo anticipates her actions and
completes her sentences effectively
silencing her not long after mateline
shows him a small plastic horse toy a
reminder from their mother this makes
him feel uneasy and he walks away saying
that it is irrelevant now on the other
hand agent Le is taken to the hospital
for his regular skin checkup before
entering the burn chamber he asks Olivia
to focus on finding commonalities among
the three victims heeding his
instructions Olivia returns back to
headquarters and starts talking to the
witnesses of the accidents after a bit
of inspection she discovers ties between
the three victims and a medical center
all three of them were directly or
indirectly related to this Center she
shares her Discovery with Charlie and
the two immediately head to this very
Medical Center upon arriving there
Olivia notices that one set of patients
are using the same ballpoint pens as
they are unable to cope with digital
devices iPads make them I mad later they
meet Dr a chief Doctor Who recognizes
all three victims of the bus accidents
after briefing them on some details
about the victims Dr L explains that
they have been helping mentally
challenged patients with experimental
processes to boost their intelligence he
also shows them video footage of their
patients in which Olivia spots Milo upon
inquiring about him Dr Levan responds
that he is one of their patients who
also went through the same drug trial
that boosted his IQ exponentially he
goes on to say that Milo was released
from the hospital under supervision of
his sister and that he was scheduled to
return back in order to reverse the
experimental process but now he is not
responding to their calls and he is
killing everyone who is trying to take
control of him after learning about
Milo's sister the FBI agents decide to
pay her a visit unbeknownst to them Milo
is keeping a close eye on Olivia noting
every single pattern of her movements
and predicting her next move later on
Charlie and Olivia arrive at Milo's
place where they are greeted to by
mateline they ask her about Milo's
whereabouts but she claims to be unaware
of them sensing that she is hiding
something the agents tell her about the
crimes he has committed and how
dangerous it is to let him roam free
while Charlie goes to investigate Milo's
room Olivia shares about her late sister
revealing how they used to care for one
another this Comforts mateline enough to
share more details about her brother she
explains that Milo is able to predict
the outcome of numerous events down to
the smallest detail and that she can
break Milo concentration only by showing
him the toy horse whenever he sees
Bullseye he gets a woody Olivia
eventually manages to persuade her to
disclose anything she knows emphasizing
that they are concerned for civilians as
well as Milo's safety mateline then
handser a note revealing the location of
the hotel that Milo is currently staying
at after this Olivia and Charlie discuss
plans with ASD on how to capture Milo
however they soon realized that any plan
would be futile because he can predict
their every move as a result they opt to
approach the hotel directly without any
backup I don't know how that's going to
help but they know best in the meantime
Milo is seen at his hotel room looking
down through the window and envisioning
scenarios that are going to happen in
the next few minutes with his ability he
predicts that Olivia and Charlie will
arrive soon and that they will chase him
he also calculates that he can kill
Olivia by luring her through a marked
zone of a construction site where the
air is too thin and crushed ring her
under a load of cement bricks just like
he predicted the two FBI agents arrive
at the hotel and find Milo waiting for
them in the street he then runs towards
the construction while the agents pursue
him Olivia who is unaware of the warning
signs for the Thin Air Zone races
through it instead of stopping to put on
a respirator this actually makes Milo's
calculation wrong he didn't think she'd
be that dumb in addition she also Dodges
a pile of cemented bricks which Milo
assumed would crush her the villain is
shocked to witness his calculation going
wrong and is ultimately caught by her at
this point in time Olivia nearly
asphyxiates herself due to the low level
of oxygen but thankfully Charlie arrives
in the nick of time and helps her with a
breathing apparatus in the aftermath of
these events Charlie asks Olivia about
why she did not stop to put on a
respirator to which she responds that
she did not recognize the warning sign
later on Olivia brings mattaline to the
hospital where Milo is seen interacting
with a supercomputer according to the
doctor the eye IQ boosting drug has been
in Milo's brain for too long due to
which they are unable to carry out the
reversal process now his mind is becomes
so Advanced that only machines can
comprehend his thoughts saddened by this
news mateline goes inside the room and
leaves the toy horse in front of her
brother the same evening Olivia is at
her place when she experiences a vision
of Peter her boyfriend from Another
Universe he tells her that she does not
belong to this universe in order to back
up his claim he reminds how her lack of
knowledge regarding this universe saved
her life earlier according to him she
would have died if she had recognized
the warning signs and stopped there
Peter encourages her to try recalling
all of her memories and also kisses her
before Vanishing subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching